hey this is just a very brief aside this
is kind of like a side story to the
immigration executive order that Donald
Trump signed yesterday which is geared
at curbing the separation from parents
and internment of migrant children I
didn't want to just mention this
hilarious thing in the main story and I
don't want to spend too much time on it
but it does bear some mentioning they
misspelled the word separation on the
executive order okay so at the macro
level and at the micro level this has
been a fiasco and a total joke the macro
is that the Trump administration has
scaled up these internments of children
it's absolutely horrifying Trump claimed
he couldn't fix it with an executive
order then he signed an executive order
and said he's fixing it so the macro is
just an absolute farce the micro is also
struggling for words
painfully dumb because the executive
order itself misspelled the word
separation and not in some footnote but
in the title okay it was originally
called the affording Congress an
opportunity to address family separation
and they spelled as you see on screen
separation se PE as opposed to the
correct spelling of se pa and it's one
of the main words of the entire thing
and in the title no less and we don't
need to belabor this it's just more
incompetence more lack of attention to
anything resembling detail and my
favorite example of this from the Trump
administration so far is when British
Prime Minister Theresa May was going to
be coming to the United States there
were some internal memos and also some
public facing documents related to her
visit and they spelled Theresa without
the H so the the Prime Minister Theresa
may spells her name with an H which is
funny because they're just misspelling
the name of the leader of one of our
leaders of one of our main allies but
it's also funny because Theresa may
without the H happens to be a British
person a British subject I think they
would be called from Surrey in the UK
who is a porn star and has starred in
such films as nude and naughty lesbian
student nurses
and the cult classic smack my [ __ ] up
so it was particularly funny that that's
how they misspelled Teresa May or how
about how when Melania Trump got out of
the hospital last month oh yeah her
kidney surgery sure and Trump
congratulated Melanie for getting out of
the hospital and doing such a great job
it's a long string of these and quite
frankly with the Theresa May thing it
wouldn't actually have been that
shocking if it were that other Theresa
May that was visiting but alas it wasn't
it was British Prime Minister Theresa
May with an H so they can't even get the
minor details correct on this entire
thing